also langsam wird es echt nervig diese
dunkle materie macht mich ganz verrückt
man sie endlich gefunden man wissen wir
endlich auf was sie besteht die neueste
entdeckung macht es auch nicht besser es
scheint so als ob es während der frühen
entwicklungsphase unseres universums
weniger dunkle materie gegeben hat wie
die forscher jetzt wieder drauf gekommen
sind bei dem science fiction heute unser
thema herzlich willkommen also wenn das
stimmt dann kann das mit den schwarzen
löchern und der dunkle materie also der
theorie von nasa wissenschaftler
alexander kuschinski dass die dunkle
materie aus schwarzen löchern besteht
eigentlich nicht stimmen aber wer weiß
so langsam werde ich ungeduldig ich will
es endlich wissen aber der reihe nach
wissenschaftler am max planck institut
für extraterrestrische physik habe unter
der leitung von reinhard genzel etwas
sehr ungewöhnliches herausgefunden
während der entstehung der frühen
galaxien von rund 10 milliarden jahren
spielt in die dunkle materie nur eine
geringe rolle es gab dort also mehr
materie als dunkle materie also ganz
anders als heute
wobei vielleicht etwas locker ein
hinweis auf die schwarzen löcher
vielleicht unterstützte sogar die these
hh sekunde
wie haben die forscher das jetzt raus
bekommen ist eigentlich relativ simpel
da liegt ja in astronomischen
dimensionen relativ langsam ist ist der
blick in die ferne auch immer ein blick
in die vergangenheit wenn wir also zum
beispiel eine sternenexplosion in 1800
lichtjahren entfernung
da hat die genau vor 1800 jahren also
ungefähr 200 jahre nach christi geburt
im jahr 200 stattgefunden
im jahr 2020 wird übrigens genau das
geschehen und wir werden eine solche
sternenexplosionen am himmel mit bloßem
auge sehen können waren wir nur noch
fünf jahre warten aber zurück zur suchte
matthée dass es sie gibt sehen wir zum
beispiel an galaxien ihre äußeren
ausläuft drehen sich viel schneller um
das zentrum der galaxie als es mit der
sichtbaren materie möglich wäre
die gravitation der sichtbaren materie
ist dafür einfach zu schwach die
erklärung es muss eine nicht sichtbare
dunkle materie geben anders ist das aber
bei den galaxien die von uns rund zehn
milliarden lichtjahre entfernt also auch
dementsprechend als sie diese halten
nicht so als ob nur wenig dunkle materie
und viel mehr normale materie
in ihnen enthalten ist die äußeren arme
bewegen sich viel mehr so wie es die
sichtbare materie vermutet also ganz
langsam oder zumindest langsamer als zum
beispiel in unserer milchstraße
die wissenschaftler untersuchten für
ihre forschung sechs massereiche
galaxien auf dem fern und damit frühen
universum dazu setzten sie das very
large telescope der europäischen
südsternwarte in chile ein
es gab also damals viel weniger dunkle
materie als heute moment das würde aber
doch wiederum für die theorie der dunkle
materie sprechen die aus schwarzen
löchern besteht einerseits andererseits
alexander klaws günstig spricht er von
schwarzen löchern gehen direkt nach dem
urknall entstanden sind
die gibt es dann dort nicht das würde
also dagegen sprechen aber die forscher
fanden nämlich auch heraus dass in
diesen galaxien noch wesentlich
turbulenter als in den heutigen galaxien
zu ging aber jetzt normalpreis schritte
zurück und zu einem kleinen
gedankenexperiment aus diesem frühen
galaxien werden ja auch irgendwann mal
häufiger galaxien und dann müssen sie
sich ja auch in den zustand verbandes
haben in denen sich heutige galaxien
befinden also mit einer menge dunkler
materie und das können sie ja wiederum
bedeuten dass sich die galaxien langsam
stabilisiert haben in dem sich immer
mehr schwarze löcher gebildet haben ja
welche bedeutung dann genau die
schwarzen löcher haben das ist ja noch
unklar zumindest beschleunigen wie aber
die äußeren spiralarme aber vielleicht
machen wir noch mehr es könnte also sein
dass ich die dunkle materie aus der
vorher normalen materie gebildet hat und
das würde wiederum bedeuten dass
alexander kaczynski nicht ganz falsch
liegt vielleicht befinden sich diese
ersten schwarzen löcher ja auch
außerhalb von galaxien und die schwarzen
löcher in den galaxien werden auf der
dortigen materie entstanden es könnte
also trotzdem sein dass die dunkle
materie aus schwarzen löchern besteht ja
so viel für ein gedankenexperiment das
sind wirklich sensationell wir mal wie
man die forschung da klarer sehen es ist
wirklich wahnsinnig spannend wie viel
hier geforscht wird und was hier ständig
veröffentlicht wird und wir bei klick
zum berichten täglich darüber zum video
wo es um die schwarze löcher und die
dunkle materie kommt ihr mit einem
einzigen klick hier keine
wissenschaftlich verpasst ihr mehr wenn
ihr mir hier ein abo aufs auge drückt
um mir dann noch einen auf die glocke
gibt viel spaß dabei und bis dann bleibt
dran